please welcome the director of hazelite
studios and last year's Game of the Year
winner for it takes two here's Joseph
Perez
yeah really nice being on stage again
actually it feels really good I know I
know a lot of people are nervous but
don't be I'm gonna be super cool and
short so
uh let's see now yeah I remember
recently uh last year winning game of
the year it's a fantastic feeling so
obviously as a nominee you should be
very happy and very proud but trust me
you do want to win because it's a great
feeling
but however you do actually win
something the game modes are super cool
because you know this beautiful
Orchestra when they play the music from
your game I mean I was sitting over
there and trust me the hair all hair on
my body was all over the place no uh
Goose pump I mean it's really awesome so
uh please give a big Applause to the
beautiful Orchestra and conducted by
long back
oh
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Goosebump I told you
[Music]
all right
Game of the Year winner is
Elder ring
foreign
[Applause]
thank you so much
[Applause]
I would like to share this great
appreciation with our entire aerodynamic
team members everybody from software our
partner Banda and Amco all collaborators
and last and but at least Mr Jordan
Martin who created the great Mythos for
this game
[Applause]
thank you
again
we have faced so many difficulties while
developing this game so as a director
I'm really relieved
and this might not be the you know light
thing to say at the you know the only
location of the
um receiving the goatee award but I
haven't made up my mind to create even
more interesting games than this one
the um
as for elderling we still have
several more things we want to do so
this getting this goatee award really
Lily and college us
all right cool so step
I'll tell you
um
foreign
and finally
um we would like to you know express our
utmost gratitude to all the fans who
played who enjoyed and supported these
titles
um and we create the games we want to
create and do our best because of you
um thank you so much
[Applause]